Narrator:
The sharks are back
in an all-New season
of "Shark tank,"
where Hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Haynes: Cinderella's proof
that one pair of shoes
can change your life.
Narrator:
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
Your branding and packaging
is terrific.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Let me ask you a question,
all right?
I just want
to finish up --
Let me ask you guys a simple --
I want to finish --
Barbara,
you're driving me crazy.
Excuse me.
You're driving me crazy.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I have a great idea.
I know I do.
I just don't think
I trust you.
Narrator: It's sink...
there are a lot of things
that sell that don't work.
...or swim.
I don't have all the answers.
That's the plan?
Uh...
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-Estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And mark cuban -- Notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First up are Neil Cameron,
Peter Ferreira,
and Dennis iannoti,
who are seeking an investment
for their pumped-Up nut butters.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Neil Cameron.
I'm Peter Ferreira.
I'm Dennis iannoti.
And we're...
ALL: Nuts 'n more.
We are seeking
$250,000
for a 20% equity stake
in our company.
Good ol' p.B.
Just got a face-Lift.
Nuts 'n more
are fortified butters
with added protein,
added omegas.
They're high in fiber
with no sugar added.
Nuts 'n more was born
this past year
in a small corner
of my family's bakery shop.
We ground lots of nuts,
mixed ingredients together,
and filled jars
by hand.
It wasn't long
before nuts 'n more
was ready for its big debut
on the shelves.
We were
instantly recognized
by Pro fitness athletes,
celebrities,
and more importantly,
nutritional stores were Buying
our products by the minute.
With your help,
we'll be able to take our nuts
to the next level,
where it belongs.
[ chuckles ]
So, sharks, are you ready
for some aggressive expansion?
Can we try it?
Absolutely.
You're gonna try it
right now.
Here you go.
We have four varieties
right now.
They're fortified
with protein and flax.
We have a peanut butter,
a chocolate peanut butter,
an Almond,
and a chocolate Almond.
Do people
like the taste?
Absolutely.
They love the taste.
The Almond butter is way better
than the peanut butter.
I love peanut butter.
Have it every morning.
So, why is it
better for me?
Because you have
double protein.
So you got 14 Grams
of protein
compared
to seven per serving.
We put flaxseed in it.
It's what gives you
the omegas -- 3, 6, 9s.
And you get
the added fiber.
So, just so we don't think
you're absolutely nuts...
[ laughter ]
...said you've only been open
a year.
Correct.
Actually,
a little less than that.
All right.
Sooner or later, we're gonna get
to this valuation of...
we'll get to it now,
I guess.
...$1.25 million...
what?
...for your company.
You've been open
a year.
Boy, let's hear it.
Cameron: Yep.
What are the sales?
So, we've actually started
selling about five months ago.
We've been open
a little less than a year.
To date,
we have $100,000 in sales.
Wow.
The valuation is
where it is
because we've been
approached
by the country's
largest national distributor.
Mm-hmm.
And they have got nine
warehouses across the country,
and if we were to put a pallet
in each warehouse,
that would be a little over
$1 million in revenue.
Okay.
Have they actually ordered?
They haven't ordered
because we can't fulfill.
What is it retailing for,
and what are you making it for?
So, the peanut retails
for $10.99.
Whoa.
And the Almond
is $12.99.
And how much
do you make it for?
We make the peanut for $2.90
and the Almond for $4.
With this investment,
we'll be able
to secure raw materials
at a much higher volume.
And bring it down.
It would bring the price
of our peanut butter down $1.50.
See if you can convince me
on the $1.3 million value.
O'Leary:
$1.250 million.
It's the brand.
The brand?
But who knows
this brand today?
Our name is starting
to become synonymous
with
the health nut butter --
CUBAN: Tell me
about the reorders.
Are you getting reorders?
We are getting --
Every single week.
Okay.
That's how many accounts?
32 retail outlets.
That's out of 35,000.
So, you got
32 retail outlets.
And we have online.
We have online.
What percentage of your business
is online?
It's about 50%.
So, you're selling
about 70 units a month
from most stores,
and they're reordering, and
they're continuing to reorder?
Reorder
almost every week.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Dennis,
I'll give you this.
It is a great name.
You guys are big guys.
You work out, obviously.
It's not, like, a guy like Kevin
selling your product.
Was that an insult?
Oh, no. Just fact.
Come on the squash court
with me. I'll kick your ass.
[ laughs ]
But I think
my challenge is this.
You're asking
for a value of the company
as though
you've already made it.
Right.
As though you've already got
all those big orders.
But we cannot commit
to these distributors
if we cannot deliver.
But that's what you need.
That's not
what the business is worth.
I mean, are you saying you need
the $250,000 in cash
to fulfill the orders,
no matter what?
Well, no.
That's to do
a few other things.
That's to staff.
That's to shore up a few of
our equipment in our facility,
to be able
to reduce our overall costs.
Right now,
we're at $2.90.
That jar
initially cost us $4.
Okay, so you're processing
and putting this all together
yourself?
Absolutely.
And you're packaging it
yourself?
Yep.
Iannoti: When we started
this brand,
we had fitness pros
come to us.
Now, these are bodybuilders.
These are bikini people.
Guys, listen. Listen.
I like you.
We're from the same tribe.
We're exactly the same.
What tribe is that,
daymond?
You know,
young, handsome, and built.
Very True.
You know it.
The issue here is,
your valuation's so crazy,
and you're working
on assumptions.
I'm a customer
but not an investor.
I'm out.
Your branding and packaging
is terrific.
That's your work?
I'm a graphic designer.
She never says that.
Thank you.
Everything's done
in-House.
I feel like I'm opening
expensive women's face cream.
This is a heartbreaker.
It really is.
Great packaging,
great name.
What a shame that you price this
at $250,000.
What a shame.
She's basically
calling you bozos.
We're here to negotiate, too,
just with you.
For me
to give you $250,000,
I would have to take
80% of the business.
I might be willing
to do it for 79%.
[ chuckles ]
let me ask you a question,
all right?
I just want
to finish up --
Let me ask you guys a simple --
I want to finish --
Barbara,
you're driving me crazy.
Excuse me.
I want
to finish one paragraph.
You're driving me crazy.
I just want to tell you
I'm so sad, but I'm out.
Now she's dead to you,
all right?
Let's move on.
That purchase order
from the distributor...
Yeah.
...there's a whole industry
of people
that give you cash
for purchase orders.
Why didn't you get
the purchase order?
It was, unfortunately,
due to fulfillment.
We need the capital to bring
the cost of the jar down
a little bit more.
What is the wholesale price
you're selling at?
Wholesale for peanut is $5.75,
and Almond is $7.25.
So, your margins
aren't big enough
'cause they don't have
the capital.
O'Leary: So, let me
take a stab at it.
No. No, I won't
give you $250,000 for 20%.
There is no chance in --
I can't even say
what I want to say.
Kevin. Kevin.
We -- Kevin.
We know
you love to wet your beak,
and we want you to be part
of the nuts 'n more team.
$250,000, I'd have to own
the whole business,
all your cars,
all your houses.
Or you can
adjust the equity.
Okay. I need 264%.
[ chuckles ]
I'm out.
Give me a total dollar amount
that you need to buy
in order to get your prices down
to where you want them to go.
About, um...$7,000.
$7,000?
Yep.
That's it?
That's just
for peanuts.
That's just the peanut.
What I'm trying
to figure out
is the least amount of cash
it'll take
to get you
to the highest margins.
Sure.
How much in aggregate
will you have to spend
to get to your optimal
cost of goods sold?
I think
mark's onto something.
Right.
If I spent $50,000,
I can fulfill that one order,
make a little bit of money,
and get my volume going.
Is that right?
Absolutely.
Mark, I think at $50,000,
they lower their price point,
and they can take orders.
I'm gonna propose something,
Robert.
Tell me
if you'd like to join me.
Yep, I'm listening.
I'm gonna propose something,
Robert.
Tell me
if you'd like to join me.
Yep, I'm listening.
We have $250,000 for 35%.
No, mark.
Hold on. Let me finish.
Let me finish.
Right?
But there's a contingency.
$75,000 in cash
up front
and then the balance
where and when you need it
to fund
future purchase orders.
So, I love that,
but I was gonna offer you
$250,000 for 50%.
I think there's a lot of value
in having two sharks.
And look, let's be honest.
You haven't
proven the business.
You've proven a concept.
You guys are nuts
if you don't take that.
Why don't you guys go think
about it?
Yeah, can we think
Yeah.
So we can
talk about it, too.
All right,
so what do you guys think?
I think
50% is way too much.
We're not
giving up 50%.
I actually like --
I like cuban's tiered.
I love it.
Because
we're gonna crush it.
You know
50% is gonna create
more problems than it solves,
simply because
there's 16% each,
and they're gonna
get resentful.
Cameron: I'd love
to have Robert in, too, but --
It's too much.
Herjavec:
These guys are tough.
They're gonna
negotiate us up.
You start at 35%,
we're gonna end up at 25%.
Let's just see
what happens.
Here they come.
Cool it.
All right, guys.
What did youse guys decide?
We would love
to have both of you.
We think
50% is too much.
We've worked
unbelievably hard,
and we are going to continue
to work hard.
We'd really love
to get you down
maybe to 30%
with that tiered approach.
'cause we can prove to you
with that approach,
you're putting
a little skin in the game
to see
what the return will be
and to know that you've made
a solid, sound investment...
...and that you've got
three guys
who are working their tails off
to get that home.
Robert,
what's your feeling?
I'm not in at 30%.
I'll go down
to mark's 35%.
35%?
35%.
You guys got a deal.
All right.
Got it.
Good job.
All right, will I look like you
if I, uh...
absolutely.
All right,
man.
Good job.
Nice job.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, guys.
Cameron: Thank you.
Have a good one.
Killed it.
Pete.
John: You know what I loved
about them?
They didn't get caught up
in the big number.
They really wanted
what they needed.
Yep.
Did you bozos just pay
a quarter million dollars
for peanut butter?
Yes.
[ laughter ]
NARRATOR:
Earlier this season,
Mike hartwick and Sarah ponn
made a deal with mark Cuban
for their unique
surf-Inspired workout,
surfset fitness.
Mark, we're gonna
accept your offer.
That's what
I'm talking about.
Ah.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Since "Shark tank,"
we've been constantly traveling.
We've actually hit
22 cities,
certifying
over 500 surfset trainers.
We'll get you listed up
on our website.
We'll get the studio open.
We've been living
in our tour bus.
It's been our mobile office
and our home,
and the demand is growing
with each stop,
and we're just Loving
every minute of it.
Four more.
Really?
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yes.
Hartwick:
Two, one, pump it up.
Ponn: Today, we're in
Los Angeles at crunch gym.
We've actually set up a deal
with mark and crunch
to roll out surfset classes
at all of their major locations.
Ponn:
Two, one, bring it up.
What's up, guys?
Mark. What's going on?
Hey, mark.
Looking good.
How are you?
Cuban:
I'm dropping in
on Mike and Sarah's classes
here today at crunch.
They've been going
full gangbusters,
and I wanted
to see them in action.
Left foot comes up,
right foot comes up, turn.
These guys are on a mission,
and I'm proud to be part of it,
and I have no doubt in my mind
that they're gonna be
every bit the Winner
I knew they would
when they came on the show.
There you go.
Nice.
Prior to going on "Shark tank,"
we did $190,000 in sales.
Is it a great class,
everybody?
You guys like it?
[ cheers and applause ]
HARTWICK:
Since going on "Shark tank,"
we've done close to $500,000
in just two months.
We're actually on track
to hit $5 million
in This first year.
It sounds corny,
but it is the american dream,
and we honestly feel
like we're living it.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is romy taormina,
whose product offers a sigh of
relief for people with nausea.
Hi, sharks.
My name is romy taormina,
and I am nausea-Relief chief
and co-Founder
of psi health solutions,
the maker of psi bands.
I am seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my business.
Psi bands are the stylish way
to quell the queasies.
They are mom-Invented,
patented,
and fda-Cleared
acupressure wrist bands
for the relief of nausea,
like for the pregnant woman
who suffers
from MORNING sickness
or the traveler who has saved
all year for a Cruise
and doesn't want to suffer
from MOTION sickness
or the CANCER patient
who is facing their next round
of chemotherapy.
I suffered from DEBILITATING
morning sickness
during both of my pregnancies
and wore acupressure wrist bands
to relieve my nausea.
But I was frustrated
with the existing products
on the market that were dated.
They stretched out over time,
and I couldn't wear them
in the shower,
or else
They'd get waterlogged.
So I created something both
fashionable and functional.
Psi bands are
uniquely waterproof,
available
in several fun colors,
and adjustable around
the circumference of the wrist,
as well as
at the acupressure point
for personalized comfort
and fit.
The adjustable orb
creates pressure
on the acupressure point
to relieve nausea.
I invite you
to invest in a company
that is already profitable.
Now I'd like
to pass out some samples.
Robert,
this is the Cherry Blossom.
Thank you, romy.
Barbara,
this is the color play.
Thank you.
And this is the block party,
Kevin.
Thank you.
Daymond.
John: Thank you.
And these will look
wonderfully on you, mark.
Romy, is there any proof
that this actually works?
It's an fda-Cleared
medical device.
That's not an answer
to the question.
No, no.
That's not what I'm asking.
What I'm asking is,
is there any medical proof
that this actually works?
Yes, there are clinical studies
that have been conducted
to effectively show
that they relieve nausea.
Why?
It's a nei guan
acupressure point,
which is located
2.5 finger Widths
above your wrist crease
between the wrist tendons.
Acupressure has been practiced
for more than 5,000 years.
It's non-Invasive,
it's affordable, and it works.
So, romy, you've been
selling these for how long?
We launched in 2007.
And what are your sales
for the last 12 months?
Almost $1 million.
Whoa.
Romy, you've sold $1 million
of these in the last 12 months?
Yes.
How?
We are selling nationally
as well as internationally.
We're selling in more than 6,000
u.S. Retail locations.
What did you make
on the $1 million?
We had 11% net profit.
Why is the profit so low?
It's not low.
You're selling $1 million,
and you're only making $110,000.
Do you take a salary
out of that?
We do.
It's $100,000.
That adds another 10%.
Walk me
through the numbers.
What does it cost you
to make this?
They retail for $15,
and we have
a 60% gross profit margin.
So, in $1 million,
your gross margin is $600,000.
Yes.
And you're clearing
$110,000.
Add your salary back.
That's $200,000.
What happened
to the other $400,000?
It goes to overhead.
It goes to bookkeeping,
rent, utilities.
Do you have any debt
in the company?
We do have debt. Yes.
How much debt do you have?
We have $600,000
in debt.
Ah.
Which includes
past deferred salaries
that we didn't take
for the first four years.
Okay,
but how much of that --
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hang on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you saying
that because you didn't
pay yourself in the past,
you consider that debt today?
Yes, I do.
Seriously?
Corcoran: Romy.
Yes.
Obviously,
your passion...
is phenomenal.
Thank you, Barbara.
No one can doubt that.
Thank you.
And the idea that you
carried forward a salary
that you thought
you should've gotten
based on the work
you already put in.
Right.
But do you know how hard
that would be for an investor
to watch you write yourself
a check
for work that happened
two years ago
against the money
that was given
to the business
by the investor?
They would hate you.
Okay.
So, are you in or are you out,
Barbara?
I'm definitely out.
Okay.
Thank you, Barbara.
What percentage of people
does this not work on?
Acupressure, there's
an individualized response,
so I can't tell you how many
it does or does not work for.
You're my biggest critics.
I'm already receiving
the cynicism,
but I can vouch
for the fact
that we have $1 million
in sales.
There's a lot of things
that sell that don't work.
But, mark, why do you
have a problem with it?
You're basically
resolving a problem
that is crushing people around
the world on an ongoing basis,
yet you really don't have
any r&d,
and you don't have
any Ongoing r&d.
You understand why I'm very,
very skeptical of this product.
We would not be able to make
the medical claims that we do
if it weren't
for our fda clearance.
No, but you're avoiding
the actual claims.
You're saying
it helps with.
Placebos help with.
It relieves --
'cause I cannot make the claim
that This is gonna help
100% of the people
100% of the time.
I can only tell you that
acupressure relieves nausea.
I understand you believe,
but that doesn't make it real.
I'm out.
Okay.
Hey, romy.
Here's where I stand.
I have no problem
with the pursuit of profit.
You can stand up there,
and you can try
to sell me whatever you want.
And I don't have any problem
with that...
until you tell me
it helps people with cancer.
I understand.
It's a very emotional thing.
Every bit of my being cringes
when you say that.
I'm out.
Okay.
O'Leary: Daymond?
John: Well, romy. Hmm.
I don't know if you're selling
Snake oil or not.
I actually tend to believe
in these things
because I do a lot of fishing,
and I get nauseous.
I mean, huge, right?
Right. Yes. Yes.
So, I was
believing in you,
but you said to me
when you came out
the company is profitable,
number one.
It's not profitable
if it has debt
and it's not paying down
the debt.
It's not the black.
I just don't think
I trust you.
That's the bigger problem.
I'm a very, very trustworthy
person, daymond.
You might be,
but today, your presentation
made me a little woozy.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I will do you a favor
because I think
your business has revenue.
I think it's growing.
Let me make you an offer,
okay?
I'm going to
give you $250,000
for 40% of your company,
all right?
Basically, about six times
your cash flow.
That's what it's worth.
Please say yes.
Taormina: No.
Why not?
I just believe
I'm gonna take this company
so much further than that.
I really stand firm
on the 10% for the $250,000.
I feel like it's very,
very reasonable and fair.
Do you want some time
to consider that offer?
No. Thank you, though,
for the offer.
Do you want
to counter it?
I have a small amount
of flexibility.
We're very far off.
No investor will ever
give you that.
Never.
Okay.
They'll go through
the same analysis I just did
and say you're very greedy,
and you're way overvalued.
I'm not giving away
40% of my company.
You're dead to me.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
They are sharks.
They will bite your head off.
When they don't believe in
something, they just go for it.
And I stand behind my product
and what it's doing for those
who suffer from nausea.
Narrator: Next up are
Nick Gonzales and Kevin Mack
with a new solution to
an otherwise permanent problem.
Hey, sharks.
I'm Nick Gonzales.
And I'm Kevin Mack
here with neo innovations,
and we're currently seeking
$80,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
There are
over 150,000 new Tattoos
being put on by Amateur
tattoo artists every month,
and half of those are gonna
suffer from tattoo regret.
That terrible feeling you get
after a tattoo
that you thought
was a good idea at the time
but ended up
to be the worst.
Well, finally,
there's an affordable method
of tattoo removal.
Black magic ipl is
an intense-Pulse light device
that uses light energy
to break up the dark pigments
in tattoo inks.
It breaks them up
without breaking
the surface of the skin.
Black magic ipl provides
affordable tattoo removal
for less
than one laser treatment.
It's so easy...
BOTH:
Anyone can do it.
Here's how it works.
Place the tip of the device on
the area that you want to treat
and pulse
one to three times,
moving forward
one-Quarter inch at a time.
The tattoo will then fade
in quarter-Inch spots
a few weeks
after treatment.
Herjavec: Do you have
any example of your skin
that where you did remove
a tattoo,
what it looked like?
Can I show you?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, this is
just one treatment.
Come on.
Yep.
So, you're saying
Those white Holes
are just
from one treatment?
One treatment.
Mack: Sharks,
here I have two balloons.
This balloon
is gonna represent
tattoo-Ink cells
underneath the skin,
while this balloon's
gonna represent
the skin on top
or around the tattoo.
As you can see,
when I pulse
or even hold on this balloon,
it is not affected
by the light
because there is
no dark pigments
to collect
the light energy.
But when I pulse on the balloon
with dark pigments...
it pops instantly.
So, sharks,
who wants to jump on board
with neo innovations...
BOTH:
And help us light the way?
[ laughter ]
I got a question.
Mm-hmm.
I'm black. Will I explode
if I put that on me?
[ laughter ]
Very good question.
There's
a scaled-Down version
where you can put
the slider control way down.
3 Watt
on up to 50 Watts,
so you could, you know,
treat depending on
the darkness of your tattoo
and what type of ink
is on your body.
You're expecting
the average person to understand
what wattage
they should Dial in
and then start
zapping their skin?
No, but it's very --
think there's any chance
people are gonna fry themselves?
No.
Wait.
This is for home use?
Home use. Yes.
Herjavec:
Oh, I didn't get that.
I thought
this had to be regulated
by somebody
who's licensed to treat you.
Our device
is nonablative,
which means that it does not
Pierce the layers of skin.
Laser treatment
doesn't Pierce the skin.
It pierces
through the top layer of skin.
But is this safe?
Yes.
It is safe. Yes.
O'Leary:
So, you send it home.
"honey,
the tattoo remover's arrived."
Minutes later,
the ambulance pulls up.
No.
Absolutely not.
How did you get there?
What's your background?
Gonzales:
I owned a tattoo shop.
Had more customers coming in
for tattoo cover-Ups
and asking
about tattoo removal.
What about the science?
Intense-Pulse light
has been around
and fda-Approved
since the '60s, so...
forever. Yeah.
O'Leary: Is it a diode
that provides the light?
No.
It's just a 50-Watt bulb.
50-Watt bulb?
50 Watts. Yeah.
That's it?
That's it. 50 Watt.
So, educate me.
You said This light
has been around forever.
Does anybody else use it
for this purpose?
Nope.
Not with
the neodymium ring magnet.
Most tattoo inks
are very magnetic
because of
the iron oxide content.
Not many people
know that.
So, you just dreamt it up
one day --
"I'm gonna shoot this guy
with a light bulb,
and his tattoo's
gonna go away"?
"I'm gonna put the laser
business out of business."
Exactly.
It's evidence-Based.
Light treatments are
the most effective way
to remove a tattoo.
So, is there
any home-Based competition?
There's a couple of other
home tattoo-Removal systems,
but they're
thousands of dollars.
Is that bulb hot
to the touch?
There is a little bit
of discomfort.
What are your sales?
Current sales --
Right now,
we keep them
at about one to two a day,
so that's about 30 to 40
a month.
How do those 30 people find you
every month?
Right now,
just amazon and ebay.
Yep.
How long
have you been doing this?
We've been doing it
for about a year and a half.
How much have you sold
in the last year?
700 units
the first year,
and we're --
about 1,200 units total.
1,200 units. How much
do the units retail for?
$139.99.
We've sold them
up to $300.
You believe you're gonna do
$200,000 in sales This year?
Most definitely.
The more we market,
the more we sell.
2% to 3% convergence rate,
whether it be on amazon,
ebay, or the website.
How easy is it to use?
It's pretty much
point and shoot.
You're saying
it's so easy,
I can just use it on myself,
and it won't hurt me?
No. Absolutely not.
No.
How many times
do I have to do it on myself
to get rid
of a tattoo like that?
If I did this whole tattoo
all at once,
it would be
90% to 100% removed.
You're saying
in one treatment,
I can get rid
of 90% of that tattoo?
My immune system's
fairly healthy.
I work out.
I drink a lot of water.
I don't drink alcohol.
I don't smoke.
So it's gonna be really quick
for people that are healthy.
Corcoran: Sorry, guys.
I'm just having
a very hard time
with the safety aspect
of this.
Is it fda approved?
Both:
The process is fda approved.
You've taken and applied
for an fda approval
for the process
and submitted your device?
And that's
where we're at now.
The fda approval firms
that we talked to
said it can cost
between $20,000 and $100,000,
and that's primarily what
we would use that money for.
And you're allowed to sell them
before the approval?
Yeah.
They said, "you're fine."
I'm having a hard time
believing this. Sorry.
I'm out.
Huge market.
Billions of dollars.
Absolutely. Yeah.
Huge demand.
It's not just
the tattoo removal.
You know,
it's the pigment disorders.
Guys,
I actually love the idea,
but I get sued for the craziest,
craziest stuff ever.
I'm just a target.
And so I just can't
take that risk.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, if I can counter that,
this is not something new.
This has been around
for decades.
No, I get that.
I get that, right?
But that doesn't make me
any less of a target.
You know, Kevin, the reason
you're not gonna get sued today
is you're two tattoo guys.
The minute I come in,
they say,
"ah, there's a shark involved.
Forget those two guys.
Let's Sue him."
So, being able
to get a device -- Any device --
Combustion engine, anything
that deals with electricity,
they're all dangerous
to buy.
So, there's ways
to get it protected
and make it where it's safe.
I don't disagree with you.
I can't get involved.
I'm out.
We do have
liability release forms
at the point of purchase.
All it takes
is one idiot to Sue you.
You don't have to have
a legitimate reason.
So, mark's out,
Barbara's out, I'm out.
Daymond, Kevin?
Well, I actually like
the business,
because I think
that's what you're building
is a business
for removing tattoos.
The numbers are great.
Liability is the issue.
It only takes one lawsuit,
which is such a headache.
And I can't
get around that.
I'm out.
You're coming
without the fda approval.
You know,
a kid gets ahold of this thing
and burns
his little brother's eye out.
And there's an easy fix
with that.
There's
just a little key switch,
on and off,
where the key --
You know,
there's protective functions
to be able
to stop all that.
I'm out.
Corcoran:
So, the lesson there
is stay poor,
and you won't get sued.
Cuban: You won't get sued.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you, sharks.
John: Thank you.
Good luck.
Mack:
This is a major industry,
and to just look over something
just because of litigation,
you know, it's...
[ scoffs ]
speechless.
[ both chuckle ]
HAYNES:
My name is Jessica Haynes,
and I'm from the small town
of Emerson, arkansas.
Growing up in a small town
is great.
Everyone is like family,
and family is important to me.
I wouldn't be where I am today
without them.
My family is very fun.
We love being outdoors
and doing things together.
My family is part of who I am.
They give me the confidence
to make crazy, risky decisions
like starting my own company.
Cheers
to family dinners on Sunday.
Yay.
Cheers.
My product is
a fashion accessory
that allows women
to transform their outfit
to match any occasion.
Okay, so it should be
mid next week?
My business is in the start-up
phase with only a prototype.
I'm trying
to secure an investment
so I can move forward
with manufacturing
and start selling my product.
I've been turned down
by countless investors.
The sharks are my last hope.
Hey, y'all.
My name is Jessica Haynes,
creator of jeska shoe company.
I'm asking for $70,000
in exchange for a 30% stake
in my company.
I've created a product
that allows women to change
the look of their shoes
as easily and as often
as we change our mind.
Imagine a seven-Day vacation.
This is just a lady's shoe bag,
and for you, gentlemen,
that means you're lugging
this precious cargo
half a mile
through the airport.
Now, imagine if you can sell
that same woman
one pair of shoes that would
match all of her outfits --
Business, casual,
and even special occasions.
That would be a shoe
that would sell itself.
The jeska high-Heeled shoe
allows women to change
the look of their shoes
from a stiletto to a wedge
with a simple push,
slide, and snap.
By releasing the safety catch,
the heel can be slid off,
and another heel can be slid
in its place.
It's that easy.
Wow.
With hidden
magnetic components
and a built-In mechanism
for interchanging heels,
our product offers women
a canvas
they can continually update
and change.
And with your help,
we can bring this product
to the masses.
Cinderella's proof
that one pair of shoes
can change your life.
Great idea.
Thank you.
John: What kind of sales
do you have
on the Mr. Potato head
for stilettos?
[ laughs ]
that's very funny.
I do not have any sales
right now.
We're still
in the prototype phase.
May I see that shoe?
Yes, ma'am.
You're not the first
to actually design a shoe
with a detachable heel
for women.
You're right.
The first patent was filed
in 1899.
Why haven't I seen it
in shoe stores?
We have seen
other products
that allow women
to transform their shoes.
I think people just haven't
partnered with the right people
and made
the right connections
in order to get it out
to the market.
But, Jessica,
there's another thesis here,
and it goes like this.
Shoe companies have
no vested interest
in reducing
the number of pairs they sell
by making
the heels interchangeable.
That does not help them
sell more shoes.
That's why the shoe companies
have not embraced this idea.
Cuban: You have
all these other shoe companies
that are spending
millions and millions of dollars
to let women know
that they exist.
How are you gonna stand out
so that people can find you?
I think
the way that we stand out
is licensing this technology
to an existing brand.
It's a huge industry.
You're a tiny, little
shoe cockroach in it.
You're scurrying around
in the dark,
trying to get some exposure
for this.
To actually compete
with the giant shoe companies,
do you think
that's gonna be easy?
I don't think
it's gonna be easy.
I don't think anything anyone
ever does in business is easy,
but I do think
it's possible.
What are you gonna
sell these for?
Right now, it is estimated
to be sold at $200 retail.
Whoa.
Do you have a patent
on that?
It is patent pending, yes.
What's the patent on?
It is for the magnets
and the interchangeable-Heel
concept.
You're giving us prices,
and you haven't made any.
Forget even selling.
Mm-hmm.
How do you know
the prices on this shoe?
I'm currently working
with a manufacturer overseas.
Okay.
And we are
in pre-Production.
They're right now building
the equipment
that is necessary
to manufacture this product.
Do you have any of your own
money invested into this?
I do.
I have a lot of my own money.
How much is it?
How much?
$63,000.
Where did you get
the $63,000 from?
When I was a young girl,
my grandfather smoked cigars,
and I made an agreement
with him.
"grandpa,
if you stop smoking cigars,
I promise
I'm gonna do good in school."
[ chuckles ]
so, he believed me, and he
set aside a college fund for me,
and he said,
"Okay, for every craving I get
"or every amount
that I would spend on cigars,
"I'll put it
into a college account
for you to use
whenever you go to college."
Nice grandpa.
Yes.
And then,
when I went to college,
I had scholarships based
on the grades that I got,
so I never actually
touched the money.
Whenever I graduated
with my masters,
I called my grandpa,
and I said,
"grandpa,
I have this crazy idea.
I want
to start a shoe company."
[ chuckles ]
and he said,
"I'm an entrepreneur myself,
and I would love for you
to follow in my footsteps."
He said, "Jessica,
if you don't take a risk,
you never get the reward."
And so that's when I used
all of that money
to go towards the company.
Eventually, that ran out.
Starting a business
I never would have thought
was so expensive.
A couple months ago,
I was at a crossroads.
I needed more money,
but I couldn't get it.
And so I actually went
to the person
that could never tell me no --
My parents.
Oh, I know this story.
They took a second mortgage out
on their home.
Were you okay with that?
[ Voice breaking ]
it was very hard
to have my parents
take that risk.
It was one thing to risk
my financial savings.
But it was very hard to put
my family in that situation.
I also --
I work full time,
and I put every dollar
that I earn into this company.
My mother did the same
for me.
I knew
that you could relate to that.
I got turned down
by 27 banks.
Mm-hmm.
My mother
put up the house,
and I moved sewing machines
in the house.
I made a factory
in the middle of Hollis, queens.
No matter how hard things got
for me,
I could never
go to my parents
because I couldn't wake up
the next day
with that pressure
on my shoulders.
Well,
you're very fortunate
that you have parents
that love you that much.
Yes, I do very much.
Here's the part
that I'm struggling with.
Perhaps the reason
this isn't out there --
Maybe women like
changing shoes.
There's also another product
out there
that offers women the ability
to change their accessories
using a snap on the toe.
It's a ballet flat
that they do it on.
And this company had $16 million
in sales in 2009.
So, Jessica, why don't you
focus on the one attribute
to your deal
that you haven't addressed
and maybe the reason
you failed --
How are you going to
get distribution?
The plan is that --
I don't have all the answers.
That's the plan?
I'm not here telling you
that I have all the answers
because that would be
a lie.
Clearly,
you don't have a plan.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
[ sighs ]
Jessica, I'm gonna make it
a little bit easier.
I just don't know anything
about the business,
so partnering with me
isn't gonna help you.
I have no idea.
I mean, I stopped wearing
shoes like that a long time ago.
[ laughs ]
but I'm out.
Thank you.
I have a price question.
Okay.
So, you're gonna be selling this
shoe with one heel for $200.
If you want a second heel,
what's that consumer
gonna pay for it?
Anywhere
between $20 and $30.
Here's what I don't like
about your plan.
You're asking someone,
in the price point
of $200, $230 a pair of shoes,
to buy your product.
I think
those people are affluent enough
to just buy two pairs
for the same price.
Oh.
And I just might add --
My first business,
I lost $42,000.
It was worth $1 billion
to me then.
I failed miserably
after two years of trying,
and you know what?
I should have given up
after three months.
I had a bad idea.
But in giving up,
I got into the right business.
I'm sure
there's a right business
right out that door
for you,
and I admire you,
your enthusiasm.
Mm-Hmm.
But I just couldn't invest,
so I'm out.
Look, if attitude and drive
were the measures of success,
you're gonna be
very, very well-Off one day.
I just can't see the business
and how you get there,
but I definitely know you're
gonna make it in something.
Thank you very much.
That means a lot.
I'm out for the shoes.
I have a great idea.
I know I do.
The interchangeable-Product
market is making millions,
and I know this product
can do that, too.
Narrator:
Four sharks are out.
Daymond is Jessica's last chance
to make a deal.
I have a great idea.
I know I do.
The interchangeable-Product
market is making millions,
and I know this product
can do that, too.
I've been told, "no" --
Like you have -- So many times.
So, "no," today Does not mean
the end of the road for me.
You're very, very early,
don't have a patent,
don't have a finished sample,
don't have experience.
All you have is debt
and a lot of courage.
[ laughs ] thank you.
All right?
[ Sniffles ]
your parents believed in you.
My parents believed in me.
And I think I'm gonna take
a Gamble and believe in you.
Oh, thank god.
[ laughs ]
I'm gonna make an offer...
but it's gonna sting.
Okay.
[ sniffles ]
I will give you
$70,000...
...for 70% of the company.
Oh, god.
Oh, come on.
Daymond!
Uh...
I have to do this job
for her.
Daymond,
you're making her an employee.
Understand
what I'm offering you.
I'm going to work
basically for you at this point.
I'm gonna teach you
every single thing I know.
I will do the distribution,
the shipping, the billing,
all that stuff.
$1 billion in orders comes in,
I'm gonna get it financed.
Every "No" Gets you closer
to a "Yes."
You're not done,
and you've got a long way to go.
John: Absolutely.
I believe
that you're gonna go
and do this
with or without me,
but I just know the work
that I have to put in,
and I'm just really investing
in you at this point.
Jessica,
what do you want to do?
A small portion of a big thing
is a lot better
than a big portion
of a small thing.
So, I take your deal.
All right! There you go.
See that?
Wow.
I got a lot of work
cut out for me.
But I'm gonna be
willing to learn.
All right.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate
all of y'all's feedback.
I really do.
Thank you.
[ sighs ]
to have a partner like that with
that much industry knowledge,
all of the contacts that I could
never even dream of getting,
and the capital, it just --
It's everything that I wanted.